So, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Peter Müller.
Herr Müller, können Sie bitte Ihre Vorname und Nachname buchstaben?
Ich höre Sie nicht so gut, ich weiß nicht woran das liegt, ich weiß nicht ob das in meinem Computer liegt.
Äh, akustisch.
Ok.
Ok, gerade ist gut oder?
Etwas besser.
Herr Müller, können Sie bitte Ihre Vorname und Nachname buchstaben?
Ja, also mein Vorname P-E-T-E-R und der Nachname M-U-L-L-E-R.
Herr Müller, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 66 Jahre alt.
Und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren 1960 am 15. Januar.
Am 15. Januar 1960.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,82 Meter.
Und gerade wie viel wiegen Sie?
Wie viel wiege ich? Vielleicht 89 Kilo?
Vielen Dank für die Informationen.
Herr Müller, was führt Sie heute zu uns? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Ich bekomme seit einiger Zeit schlecht Luft.
Entschuldigung, ich habe nicht Sie akustisch verstehen können. Können Sie bitte wiederholen?
Schlecht Luft, ok. Seit einigen Stunden.
Und gerade haben Sie...
Ich habe nicht Stunden gesagt, ich habe gesagt, dass ich seit einiger Zeit schlecht Luft bekomme.
Einigen Zeiten, Entschuldigung.
Einiger Zeit.
Ja, und wie zum Beispiel seit einer Stunde oder... können Sie wieder ganz genau sagen?
Können Sie das bitte etwas genauer sagen?
Meinen Sie damit Stunden, Tage, Wochen oder Monate?
Können Sie bitte etwas genauer sagen? Stunde, Tage oder Woche?
Genau. Ich habe schon seit ein paar Wochen, also schon seit bestimmt drei Monaten geht das so.
Und es wird immer schlimmer.
Sie kriegen schwer Luft.
Hab ich richtig verstanden? Ok.
Und ja, gerade bei der Station haben Sie Schwierigkeit bei Luft kriegen.
Bitte?
Gerade momentan.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeit beim Luft kriegen?
Beim Luft kriegen sagt man glaube ich so nicht.
Haben Sie gerade das Problem, haben Sie momentan Probleme, Luft zu kriegen?
Beim Atmen oder?
Beim Atmen geht es auch genau.
Ja, habe ich ehrlich gesagt. Also ich habe das Gefühl, das ist heute ganz schlimm.
Also es ist schon seit Wochen so, aber jetzt heute ist ganz schlimm.
Herr Müller, gerade muss ich die Aufnahme des Geschlechts unterbrechen und ihre vitalen Parameter prüfen.
Alles ok, dann können wir weitermachen.
Ja, ich bitte darum, bitte.
Dann wir haben gemacht und dann können wir weitermachen.
Super.
Ok.
Ja, begleitend haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Die Luftnot schränkt mich schon sehr ein, das ist schon richtig schlimm.
Ok, und was heißt Luftnot? Zum Beispiel Brustschmerz, Husten?
Schmerzen würde ich das nicht nennen, das ist eher so wie Beklemmung.
Beklemmung? Sie können nicht die Duft rausbringen, oder? Wie meinen Sie mit Beklemmung?
Beklemmung? Wissen Sie nicht was Beklemmung ist? Beklemmung ist Einengung, Beklemmung.
Ich habe in der Brust das Gefühl einer Beklemmung.
Wie ein Engelgefühl?
Richtig.
Ok, und dieses Engelgefühl auch haben Sie seit drei Monaten, oder?
Haben Sie das Engelgefühl auch seit drei Monaten?
Haben Sie dieses Engelgefühl auch seit drei Monaten?
Nein. Ja, ich habe das schon länger nicht seit drei Monaten, das kam dann irgendwann dazu.
Ich kann nicht, das bedeutet also Beklemmung heißt, ich kann nicht richtig einatmen.
Es ist schwer einfach, ich kriege die Luft nicht rein.
Ok, und ja, ich habe schon gefragt, haben Sie auch Husten?
Ja, nein, nicht wirklich, so ganz leicht manchmal wie so ein Reizhusten.
Reizhusten. Und diese Luftnot, haben Sie diese Luftnot zum Beispiel bei Belastung oder auch im Ruhe?
Ja, vor allen Dingen bei Belastung. Ich kriege zu Hause komme ich die Treppe auch nicht mehr so gut hoch ohne Luftnot.
Vor allen Dingen beim Treppensteigen.
Ok, und benutzen Sie mehr Kisten beim Schlafen als früher?
Ah, als sonst, ne? Als sonst. Ja, ich kann nicht mehr flach schlafen, das geht nicht mehr.
Ok, und haben Sie auch Kraftminderung in letzter Zeit?
Ja, ich bin sehr schwach jetzt. Ich kann ja nicht mehr viel machen, weil ich Luftnot habe.
Ich kann tägliche Aufgaben nicht mehr erledigen ohne Luftnot.
Ich verstehe Sie. Und ja, Sie haben schon gesagt, auch die Schmerzen nicht sehr.
Sie haben schon gesagt, auch geht nicht, dieses auch immer falsch positioniert. Sie haben auch schon gesagt oder?
Sie haben auch schon gesagt, dass Sie die Schmerzen nicht genau haben.
Keine richtigen Schmerzen haben, dass Sie keine richtigen Schmerzen haben, genau?
Ja, aber zum Beispiel, ich möchte auch fragen, ob bei Belastung haben Sie auch Schmerzen im Brust oder?
Ob ich unter Belastung, vor allen Dingen unter Belastung Beschwerden habe in der Brust.
Das wird nicht mehr bei Belastung. Bei Belastung habe ich mehr Luftnot.
Haben Sie geschwollene Beine? Oh ja, meine Beine sind dick.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass rechts etwas dicker ist als links.
Ja, dicker als vorher. Nicht ganz.
Beide Beine sind dicker als sonst.
Und ich habe das Gefühl, dass rechts sogar noch dicker ist als links.
Rechts, okay.
Dicker als linke Seite.
Okay, haben Sie Schüttelfrost, Schweißausbruch, Nachtschweiß,
Herzrasen, Herzklopfen?
Schüttelfrost, Nachtschweiß, Gewichtsverlust, das habe ich alles nicht.
Aber wenn ich mich anstrengen, habe ich Herzrasen.
Wenn ich anstrengen und habe ich Luftnot und Herzrasen.
Man kann sagen, beschwerdeabhängige Herzrasen.
Richtig, genau.
Und es ist mir aufgefallen, dass die Beine vor allen Dingen abends dicker sind als tagsüber.
Abends, okay, das ist auch sehr wichtig.
Als tagsüber.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewöhnlich Gewicht ab und zu genommen?
Nein, ja, ich habe jetzt zugenommen, weil ich viel Wasser im Körper habe.
Wie viel Kilogramm und in welcher Zeit kaum?
Also in den letzten drei Monaten habe ich bestimmt acht Kilo zugenommen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen, Stuhlgang?
Momentan habe ich eher das Problem, dass ich zu viel Wasser lasse, vor allen Dingen nachts.
Vor allen Dingen nachts, da muss ich ständig aufstehen.
Viel Wasser lassen?
Mhm.
Haben Sie übermäßige Durst?
Das bin ich aufgefallen.
Okay, und müssen Sie häufig zur Toilette gehen, oder?
Ja, habe ich ja gesagt, vor allen Dingen nachts.
Haben Sie in der Zeit irgendwelche Medikamente?
Ich habe Bluthochdruckmedikamente.
Und was ist die Name?
Bitte?
Können Sie bitte, wie ist die Name des Medikamentes?
Ich nehme momentan 5 Milligramm Ramipril ein, morgens und abends.
Und der Haushalt hat mir noch ein Medikament gegeben, 10 Milligramm.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es heißt.
Ich muss das einnehmen, weil ich zu viel Wasser im Körper habe.
HST oder Phurosemite?
Erinnern Sie sich?
HCT ist es nicht, Phurosemite auch nicht.
Das sind 10 Milligramm.
Spirulonkton, okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Mein Appetit?
Na ja, mir geht es schlecht. Wie soll man denn da Appetit haben?
Ich fühle mich nicht gut, ich habe Luftnot, da kann man nicht gut essen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Blehungen?
Blechsucht?
Was für eine Sucht?
Blechsucht.
Vollige für den Bauch.
Bläsucht? Gibt es das Wort?
Ja, ich meinte Blechungen.
Ja, Blehungen, wissen Sie, ich bin momentan überall so geschwollen,
dass ich Ihnen das nicht genau sagen kann.
Aber Sie haben keine volle Gefühl?
Ich habe Luftnot.
Ich kann das nicht differenzieren, ob da volle Gefühl mit dabei ist oder nicht.
Mich belastet vor allen Dingen die Luftnot momentan.
Okay. Entschuldigung, vielleicht habe ich gefragt, aber ich erinnere mich nicht genau.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Herr Hamula, haben Sie irgendwelche Allergie?
Pelizilinalergie.
Wie äußert Sie oder wie reagiert Sie?
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Wissen Sie, ich habe das einmal gekriegt, da hatte ich eine Lungenentzündung.
Und das war ganz schlimm, weil ich habe dann ganz schlimm reagiert.
Und eigentlich war es sowieso falsch, weil ich hätte eine andere Santibiotikung kriegen müssen.
Denn wegen meiner Lungenentzündung auf jeden Fall war das so,
dass ich im ganzen Körper Ausschlag hatte und Luftnot bekommen habe.
Und dann hat man zu mir gesagt, dass ich eine Penicillinallergie habe
und dass ich nie wieder Penicillin haben darf.
Okay. Wir achten auf diese Situation.
Und haben Sie auch...
Nein, wir passen auch auf. Wir werden auch aufpassen.
Wir passen. Okay.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Unverfähigkeit?
Zum Beispiel, wenn Sie etwas essen, dann nach dem Essen füllen Sie sich schlecht.
Nein. Nein, habe ich nicht.
Okay. Und haben Sie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Ich meine, Zuckerkrankheit, Bluthochdruck oder irgendwelche Krebs?
Superkrankheit? Was ist eine Superkrankheit?
Zuckerkrankheit. Zucker. Zuckerkrankheit.
Nein, Diabetes habe ich nicht, aber ich habe einen Bluthochdruck.
Seit wann?
Ich bin 66 Jahre alt. Ich bin schon über 20 Jahre.
Ich habe schon einen Bluthochdruck. Seit 20 Jahren.
Stimmt, 20 Jahre.
Okay. Und die Medikamente, die Sie schon haben, nehmen Sie dagegen?
Noch mal.
Dagegen nehmen Sie Medikamente, die Sie schon erwähnt haben?
Ja, genau.
Ich nehme RamiPril ein. Das ist das einzige Medikament, das ich zurzeit einnehme.
Und der Haushalt hat mir diese 10 mg aufgeschrieben.
Und diese 10 mg sind einmal täglich?
Er hat gesagt, ich soll es vor allen Dingen morgens einnehmen,
weil sonst muss ich nachts noch mehr aufstehen auf die Toilette, hat er gesagt.
Das ist ein harentreibendes Medikament?
Ja, genau. Er hat gesagt, es ist harentreibend.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente außerhalb dieser Medikamente ein?
Nicht außerhalb, sondern außer diesen Medikamenten?
Außer.
Sie meinen so Vitamine oder was meinen Sie?
Egal.
Nein, ich nehme nicht ein, wirklich nicht. Glauben Sie mir.
Ich nehme nur die Medikamente ein, mehr nicht.
Okay, Herr Müller, rauchen Sie?
Ich habe früher geraucht, aber ich rauche nicht mehr.
Okay, und wie lange und wie viel haben Sie geraucht?
Boah, das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich habe vor 10 Jahren aufgehört und ich habe bestimmt 20 Jahre lang geraucht, eine Packung am Tag.
Vertrinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol?
Ja.
Nein, ich trinke keinen Alkohol.
Hatten Sie oder haben Sie Kontakt mit irgendwelchen Drogen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Ja, bitte nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Ach so, nein, ich nehme keine Drogen. Hören Sie mal.
Schön.
Okay, und sind Sie vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheit und Corona geimpft?
Ja, eigentlich schon.
In letzter Zeit waren Sie im Ausland?
Meinen Sie in letzter Zeit mein letztes Jahr oder dieses Jahr?
Sechs Monate.
Nein, nein. In den letzten sechs Monaten war ich nicht im Ausland.
Und in Ihrer Familie gibt es irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen?
Ich meine bei Ihrem Vater, Ihrer Mutter, falls Sie Geschwister haben, bei Ihnen.
Meine Mutter war gesund, die hatte eigentlich keine besonderen Erkrankungen.
Und mein Vater, mein Vater hatte Bluthochdruck, habe ich glaube ich von ihm die Gene geerbt.
Dann hat mein Vater auch noch irgendwas am Herz gemacht bekommen.
Ich weiß immer nicht was, die haben irgendwas aufgemacht, die Gefäße aufgemacht.
Gefäße, wie eine Operation oder?
Das war keine richtige Operation, die haben das ambulant gemacht.
Die haben Ihnen, naja, ich weiß nicht genau.
Ein Herzkatheter?
Ja, genau, die haben einen Herzkatheter gemacht. Und da haben die irgendein Gefäß aufgemacht.
Ich weiß nicht wie viele Gefäße, aber die haben was aufgemacht, haben Sie gesagt.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Aber mein Vater ist das noch nicht alles fertig, der hat ja noch.
Ah, okay, bitte.
Genau, der hat eine COPD noch und er hat Diabetes.
Ja, gegen Diabetes nimmt er irgendwelche Medikamente oder Spritze.
Ja, Metformin nimmt er ein, glaube ich.
Insulinspritzen der nicht, Tabletten, ich glaube Metformin.
Metformin, okay. Vielen Dank.
Und noch gibt es andere Erkrankungen bei Ihrem Vater?
Noch auch diese Sachen immer und noch gibt es noch.
Erst das Werb und dann gibt es noch.
Nein, das war's. Das reicht auch, Herr Doktor.
Natürlich.
Ja, sind Sie verheiratet, oder?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe Kinder, ich habe drei Kinder.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, sind gut und sind auch schon erwachsen.
Okay, und was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin jetzt berentet.
Ich bin ja 66 Jahre alt.
Und früher?
Anwalt.
Anwalt, okay.
Treiben Sie Sport?
Ja, ich mache regelmäßig Sport.
Jetzt natürlich mit dieser Luftnot schon lange nicht mehr, das geht nicht mehr.
Aber vorher bin ich regelmäßig Fahrrad gefahren.
Das ist auch Sport, oder Herr Doktor?
Natürlich.
Ja, alles ist Sport, die unsere Körper bewegen lassen.
Ja, Herr Müller, gerade bin ich mit meinen Fragen fertig.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, helfen Sie mir bitte, diese Luftnot, das ist schlimm.
Und ich möchte die gerne loswerden.
Ja, okay, wir machen alle.
Es gibt noch zwei Schritte.
Zuerst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Anschließend nehme ich Ihnen etwas Blut ab.
So wie ein paar operative Untersuchungen durchführen.
Wenn alle Befunde vorliegen, besprechen ich mit meinem Oberarzt.
Und dann kommen Sie zurück.
Dann werden wir für den Schritt vorgehen.
Okay, alles klar.
Entschuldigung, ich habe eine Frage.
Ja?
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben Leichte Husten.
Ist das Husten mit Auswurf oder mit Tröcken?
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe Reizhusten.
Reiz ist die Nominative.
Reiz, Reiz.
Reizhusten.
Ist die Frage beantwortet?
Wie?
Das war, ist beantwortet, das mit dem Reizhusten.
Ja.
Soll ich noch fragen?
Ich weiß gar nicht, gibt es im Chat Fragen?
Nein, wir können ja weitermachen.
Oder wollen Sie noch etwas gucken?
Ich brauche ein paar.
Ja, okay, gerne.
Guten Tag, Frau Oberarztin.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und möchte Ihnen gerne vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurze Zeit für mich?
Ja, bitte, legen Sie los.
Herr Peter Müller, 66 Jahre alt, 1,82 Meter groß, 89 kg schwer.
Stellte Sie heute bei uns vor.
89 kg schwer, da müssen Sie kg dazu sagen.
Kilo, schwer.
Stellte Sie heute bei uns vor.
Der Patient klagte über seit 3 Monaten bestehende, langsam aufgetretene Zunehmende, Dyspnoe und Leichthusten.
Außerdem berichtete der Patient über ein enges Gefühl im Brustkorb.
Dyspnoe würde in Form einer Atmungsstörung beschrieben.
Nein.
Denkt Sie mal, den Husten würde als unproduktiv beschrieben.
Ich habe nicht gesagt.
Reishusten.
Ja, er beklagt Reishusten Reißschon.
Das ist ja unproduktiv.
Reishusten ist das hier.
So wie bei ACE Hämmerhusten.
Die Hase ist ein bisschen schädig.
Genau, reizt einfach.
Laut Angabe des Patients sind Zirraten, die beschwerten häufigst bei Belastung.
So sieht es sich der Patient an, dass er in beiden Beinen Däme hat, die am Abend sich verschlechter geworden sind.
Nochmal den Satz.
Laut Angabe des Patients sind Zirraten, die beschwerten häufigst bei Belastung.
So sieht es sich der Patient an, dass er in beiden Beinen Däme hat, die am Abend sich verschlechtern werden.
Die sich am Abend verschlechtern würden.
Oder die mit Zunahme am Abend zunehmen würden.
Die abends zunehmen würden.
Ganz einfach.
Die nehmen ja zu die Ödeme.
Zunehmen?
Ja, die Ödeme nehmen zu heißt die Ödeme werden mehr.
Oder sagen Sie einfach, die am Abend mehr werden würden.
Oder die am Abend zunehmen würden.
Die Ödeme nehmen zu oder sie werden mehr?
Ja.
Des Weiteren erwähnte er ungewöhnliche Gewichtverlust von 6 Kilo innerhalb 3 Nagen.
Nein.
Riecht 8 Kilo.
Nein, ich habe nicht gesagt Gewichtsverlust.
Sie haben mich gefragt, ob ich Gewicht, ich habe gesagt, dass ich den zu genommen habe.
Entschuldigung, ich habe den zu genommen.
Genau, Gewichtzunahme.
Gewichtzunahme innerhalb 3 Monaten.
Von 8 Kilo.
Gewichtzunahme von 8 Kilo in den letzten 3 Monaten.
Ich vonlebe am Anfang.
Des Weiteren erwähnte er Gewichtzunahme von 8 Kilo innerhalb 3 Monaten.
Ja, Anforderkrankungen bestehen eine Artehyla Hypatonie seit 20 Jahren,
die mit Rami-Bril 2x, 5 mg, 2x täglich behandelt wird und eine, die Name nicht wusste.
Bitte, eine was?
Die Name.
Die Name gibt es nicht.
Der Name.
Der Name nicht.
Und ein weiteres Medikament, dessen Name der Patient nicht wusste.
Und ein weiteres Medikament.
Ein weiteres Medikament, dessen Name der Patient nicht wusste.
Noch einfacher, er nimmt noch ein weiteres Medikament ein, der Patient kennt den Namen nicht.
Okay, dann vielleicht später kann ich.
Das ist einfach zu nehmen, was für Sie am einfachsten ist.
Er nimmt noch ein anderes Medikament ein, aber er kennt den Namen nicht.
Ja, noch ein anderes Medikament.
Das Medikament, ein anderes Medikament.
Das Medikament, anderes Medikament.
Die Medikamente, andere Medikamente.
Ein Medikament, ein anderes Medikament, Patient kennt aber den Namen nicht.
Okay.
Ja, Patient kennt den Namen nicht, wusste er.
Okay, und 10 mg, einmal täglich behandelt wird.
Und er ist, er hat circa 20 Jahre lang geraugt, einpacken täglich.
Und er trinkt keinen Alkohol, er hat keinen Kontakt mit Drogen.
Wie nennt man das, wenn ein Patient 20 Jahre lang eine Packung Zigaretten am Tag raucht?
Wie nennt man das, abgekürzt?
Er hat 20 Pack-Ears, ne?
Er hat 20 Jahre lang eine Packung Zigaretten.
Das weiß ich, das ist alles korrekt.
Aber das heißt, wenn er sich fragt, das sind 20 Pack-Ears, ne?
Natürlich, so.
Genau, okay, weiter.
Und er hat vor 10 Jahren mit Rauchen aufgehört.
Er trinkt keinen Alkohol, er hat keinen Kontakt mit Drogen.
Impfstatus ist vollständig.
Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
In der Family-Anamnese, der Vater leidet an arterialen Hypatonien,
herrschte Kranz-Störungen.
Nein, nein.
Koronare Arterien oder Koronare Arterstörungen.
Bitte keine Störungen.
Es gibt keine Koronare Arterien, keine Herz-Kranz-Störungen.
Es gibt eine Herz-Kranz-Erkrankung, und das ist eine Kahaka.
Es gibt eine Koronare Herz-Krankheit.
Der Vater leidet an einer Koronaren Herz-Krankheit, oder sagen Sie einfach Kahaka?
Der Vater leidet an einer Kahaka.
Wenn Ihnen das zu schwer fällt, sagen Sie Kahaka.
Wenn er Sie fragt, was ist Kahaka, dann müssen Sie sagen, Koronare Herz-Erkrankung.
Störung, weg, alles weg.
Okay, Kranken, ja, natürlich.
Eine COPD und Diabetes mellitus Typ 2.
Die Mutter ist gesund.
Er ist verheiratet, hat zwei gesunde Kinder.
Drei gesunde Kinder.
Drei Kinder.
Er ist gerade Rentner.
Früher arbeitete er als Anwalt.
Er ist gerade berentet, würde ich nicht sagen.
Er ist mittlerweile berentet.
Er treibt nicht gerade Sport.
Früher hat er Fahrrad gefahren.
Er ist früher viel Fahrrad gefahren.
Ist gefahren.
Nicht hat gefahren.
Gefahrt gibt es nicht.
Das fallen Sie durch.
Gefahren.
Perfekt ist gefahren.
Vergangenheit ist gefahren.
Bei fahren gibt es Fahrtgefahrt nicht.
Das gibt es nicht.
Es gibt nur Gefahren.
Ich bin gefahren, du bist gefahren.
Ja, hier natürlich.
Oder er fährt, sie fährt.
Sie fährt Fahrrad, er fährt Fahrrad.
Aber er ist gefahren.
Es wäre besser, wenn wir sagen, er fährt früher Fahrrad.
Nein.
Früher ist Vergangenheit.
Er ist früher viel Fahrrad gefahren.
Und prätiert und fährt.
Er fuhr.
Er fuhr früher Fahrrad.
Ja.
Aufgrund der Symptomatik habe ich den Verdacht auf eine Herzinfizienz.
Rechte Herzinfizienz oder rechtsseitige Herzinfizienz?
Bitte nicht genauer sagen.
Es reicht Herzinfizienz erst mal.
Ich habe den Verdacht auf eine Herzinfizienz.
Warum kommen Sie auf eine Rechtsherzinfizienz?
Warum?
Ja, dafür sprechen zum Beispiel langseitige Düstpneu.
Ja, was macht eine Düstpneu?
Rechtsherzinfizienz macht eine Düstpneu?
Oder was macht eine Düstpneu?
Das ist einfach ...
Linksherzinfizienz macht eine Düstpneu.
Warum?
Weil im Lungen gibt ...
Genau. Und damit das in die Lungen kommt,
muss man erst mal eine Linksherzinfizienz haben.
Wie kommen Sie auf eine Rechtsherzinfizienz?
Bitte nicht.
Herzinfizienz war schon gut.
Also nichts was sagen, was man gefragt werden kann.
Erst mal alles grob.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass der Patient eine Herzinfizienz hat.
Auf unsere Ödämme haben Sie diese Pfeife.
Ja, okay. Aber das können Sie später noch sagen.
Er kann ja dann sagen, lassen Sie ihn doch fragen.
Der Pfeifer muss ja erst mal das Gefühl haben,
ich frage mal weiter.
Dann lassen Sie ihn doch.
Dann können Sie sagen, vielleicht ist es eher mehr eine Rechtsproblematik
als eine Linksherzproblematik.
Weil er hat Ödämme, aber Linksherzinfizienz macht auch Ödämme.
Natürlich.
Okay, also ich gehe von einer Herzinfizienz aus.
Okay, gut, weiter.
Warum?
Wie ich schon gesagt habe,
diese Beine und eigentlich belastungsabhängige Dispne.
Und was noch?
Und diese Beine damit haben.
Was ist noch typisch, dass er eine Herzinfizienz hat?
Er muss vor allen Dingen nachts aufstehen zum Wasser lassen.
Er hat eine Nykthorie.
Und er muss den Oberkörper hochschlafen.
Ja, und auch die Körper hochschlagen.
Und als Differenzialdiagnose kommen auch Lungenembolien.
Warum? Wie kommen Sie auf die Lungenembolien?
Ja, die geschwollene Beine und auch die Dispne.
Kann auch zum Beispiel eine Dungenembolie, Ferrozacht.
Ja, aber was vor allen Dingen?
Was vor allen Dingen habe ich extra gesagt,
dass Sie auch an die Lungenembolien denken?
Was habe ich gesagt?
Ich habe gesagt, beide Beine sind dick,
aber habe ich gesagt, das rechte Bein ist dicker als das linke Bein.
Das müssen Sie sagen.
Das hat er extra gesagt.
Habe ich extra gesagt.
Das könnte auch eine Lungenembolie sein, aber es reicht schon.
Die Symptomatik reicht schon.
Vor allen Dingen hat er gesagt,
dass ein Bein dicker ist als das andere.
Das könnte sein, dass da vielleicht doch noch eine Thrombose drinsteckt.
Aber das stimmt.
Die Symptomatik reicht schon aus,
aber ich habe extra gesagt, das eine Bein ist dicker.
Okay, was noch?
Und auch eine metabolische Syndrom.
Aufgrund der ein bisschen Übergewicht und arterieller Hypertonie
und typischer Beschwerden, Kraftminderung.
Ja, aber ein metabolisches Syndrom ist ein Syndrom
und das macht keine akuten Beschwerden.
Das würde ich jetzt nicht erwähnen.
Hallo?
Hören Sie mich?
Ja, ja, wir hören Sie.
Ich kann aber den Patienten, den Arzt nicht mehr lernen.
Das ist weg.
Ach so, das ist bei allen weg.
Wir warten noch ein bisschen kurz auf die Seite.
Ja?
Sie haben ein Verbindungsproblem, oder?
Entschuldigung, ich habe ein Problem mit der Verbindung.
Aber soll ich etwas sagen?
Jetzt ist auch die Stimme super.
Jetzt höre ich Sie auch besser.
Diesmal habe ich über Ihr Handy verbunden.
Diesmal bin ich über Handy verbunden.
Diesmal habe ich mich über Handy verbunden.
Sehr gut, okay.
Ja, wir sind stehengeblieben bei Differentialdiagnose.
Sie haben gesagt, Differentialdiagnose Lungenembolie.
Das war gut.
Und das zweite, das dritte, haben Sie gesagt,
Metabolisches Syndrom, bitte nicht Metabolisches Syndrom
als akute Erkrankung, Differentialdiagnose jetzt in dem Fall nennen.
Zumal der Patient ist nicht super dick, ja,
der ist nicht sehr übergewicht, der ist 1,82 groß
und der ist nur 89 Kilogramm schwer.
Das ist nicht viel für einen Mann.
Das heißt, der Mann ist normalgewicht.
Metabolisches Syndrom bedeutet immer Übergewicht.
Er hat kein Übergewicht.
Also Metabolisches Syndrom bitte nicht erwähnen.
Bitte nichts erwähnen, wo man sich nicht sicher ist.
Es geht jetzt um das Erkrankungsbild Luftnot.
Metabolisches Syndrom macht keine Luftnot.
Das ist keine akute Erkrankung.
Also, wir vergessen das sofort.
Herzunsuffizienz war richtig, Lungenembolie war richtig.
Okay.
Richtig, genau, COPD kann es sein.
Lungenentzündung kann es sein, sowas.
Erstmal, Entschuldigung, auch trotzdem immer daran denken,
auch wenn das alles nahe liegt, er hat Beklemmung in der Brust
und der Vater hat eine KHK.
Also muss man auch bei diesem Patienten...
Natürlich, natürlich.
Das gehört zu den ersten Diagnosen, die man sendt.
Herzunsuffizienz, ACS, Lungenembolie.
Diese drei Sachen sind die wichtigsten,
die man ausschließen muss.
Das müssen Sie sagen.
Es kann ja sein, dass der Patient vor drei Monaten
einen Herzinfarkt hatte, er hat das nicht gemerkt.
Und jetzt hat er eine Herzunsuffizienz nach dem Infarkt.
Kann ja sein.
Ja, okay, alles klar.
Ja, um den Verdacht zu bestätigen,
planen ich folgende diagnostische Maßnahmen.
Zuerst werde ich den Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Und bei der körperlichen Untersuchung
achte ich auf Herz-Oskultation und Lungen-Oskultation.
Was hören Sie denn in der Lunge?
Was erwarten Sie denn?
Wie können bei Oskultation eine z.B.
gedämpfte oder, Entschuldigung, eine Stridor z.B.
Warum erwarten Sie eine Stridor?
Gucken Sie mal, Sie haben gesagt,
die erste Verdachtdiagnose ist Herzunsuffizienz.
Was passiert bei Herzunsuffizienz?
Und ja, Flüssigkeit, Anzahlung in den Lungen.
Ja, was hören Sie denn, wenn die Lunge voll ist mit was?
Rasselgeräusche. Sie hören erst mal Rasselgeräusche.
Ja, natürlich.
So, Sie hören Rasselgeräusche.
Stridor ist etwas ganz anderes.
Stridor beim Hastnacht.
Sie können sagen, Sie können Spastic hören.
Stridor gehört ja ab und zu.
Aber Stridor ist ja eher etwas ganz anderes.
Es ist ja eher mehr so,
wie soll ich sagen, wenn Epiglottis II ist oder so.
Stridor. Aber Spastic hören Sie.
Spastic.
Verlängertes Expiratorium zum Beispiel hören Sie.
Warum? Weil Sie gesagt haben,
COPD zum Beispiel.
Wo dieses Imen, dieses Spastic,
hört man auf Patienten, wenn die schon im Lungenödem sind.
Ja.
Wenn die schon im Lungenödem sind,
hört man nicht das typische Rasselgeräusch.
Man hört dann dieses Brodeln.
Ja, und man hört Spastic auch.
Das ist manchmal nur Spastic wegen COPD.
Das habe ich im Notfall immer,
wenn ich als Notärztin bei Patienten bin.
Oder die haben das feine Imen.
Feine Imen.
Das ist, wenn die Lungenödem haben,
hört sich das genauso an.
Mhm.
Okay, also fangen Sie bitte, denken Sie bitte strategisch.
Sie haben gesagt Herzunsuffizienz.
Dann müssen Sie auch sagen,
was Sie das erste hören bei Herzunsuffizienz.
Ja, ich habe ja gesagt,
der Patient könnte eine Herzunsuffizienz haben
oder ein ACS oder halt eine Lungenembolie.
Und entweder der Patient hat Rasselgeräusche,
weil er Wasser in der Lunge hat.
Er kann auch ein bisschen Spastic haben.
Er kann aber auch komplett aufgehobene Atemgeräusche,
basale Abschnitte der Lunge haben,
wenn er schon Ploreregüsse hat.
Der Mann hat das schon seit 3 Monaten.
Das ist schon ein chronischer Zustand.
Das bedeutet,
wahrscheinlich hat er schon Ploreregüsse.
Ja, nein.
Okay, habe ich verstanden?
Ja.
Okay, alles klar.
Und dann gehen wir über aufs Herz.
Dann höre ich das Herz ab.
Was hören Sie am Herzen?
Ja, bei der Herz-Osputation.
Vielleicht kann ich
wie man sagt,
verminderte Herzgeräusche
und einen Herzrasen.
Herzrasen, ja.
Und welche Erkrankungen
führt bei älteren Menschen
auch zu einer kardialen Dekompensation?
Welche Herzerkrankungen, was man hören kann?
Klapp in der Klappe?
Stenose, Kalkung.
Alte Menschen Kalk.
Kalk am Herzen, Kalk an der Klappe.
Okay? Für alle.
Alt,
junge Menschen nicht.
Er Endokaditis, alte Menschen.
Wenn er alt ist,
junge Menschen haben eher Insuffizienz,
weil da irgendwas reißt oder so.
Aber bei alten Menschen Kalk, Kalk, Kalk,
Herzkalk,
K.H.K. oder auch eine Klappenstenose.
Was hören Sie denn dann?
Typischerweise.
Ja, Geräusche.
Welches Geräusch?
Schlau.
Man hört immer,
merken Sie sich nur auf
die Kalkenstenose, die anderen sind nicht so wichtig.
Man hört dann ein Systolicum.
Systolicum, genau.
Zweiter ICR rechts.
Detail wissen muss nicht sein.
Aber vielleicht fragt er. Egal.
Und ja, bei der
Labo veranlasse ich
eine Großblutknehe.
Wenn Sie ein verschiedene Worte sagen.
Wenn Sie sagen, ja, ich höre das Herz ab,
ich höre dann die Lunge ab,
ich höre dann das Mal, ich mache eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Vielleicht will er das ja gar nicht wissen.
Aber am Anfang habe ich gesagt,
dass Herz und Lunge abloppen.
Worauf achten Sie noch?
Sie gehen ja erst mal von der Herzunzufizienz an.
Wenn Sie ihn körperlich untersuchen.
Lunge ist ganz wichtig.
Das müssen Sie sagen, wenn Sie Herzunzufizienz sagen.
Wenn Sie sagen, Ihre Heropdiagnose
ist Herzunzufizienz, müssen Sie auch sagen,
dass Sie die Lunge aushorchen,
Hustlegeräusche hören können, Spastik hören können, bei Lungenödemen.
Oder pleuralgüste,
abgeschwächte Atemgeräusche, Beizweissatzbasal.
Was müssen Sie sagen?
Herzunzufizienz.
Worauf müssen Sie noch bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achten,
wenn Sie Herzunzufizienz gesagt haben?
Wenn Sie Herzunzufizienz gesagt haben?
Ja, natürlich muss ich...
Ich muss
Leber auch palpieren.
Nein, das ist nicht das allererste, was Sie sagen.
Ja, ich will eine Bein-
Ja, ja, ich gucke mir die Extremitäten an.
Ich denke auf die Beinschwellungen.
Ich denke.
Und was ist das?
Und man kann sich die Jugularis noch anschauen.
Jugularis, ja.
Ach, reicht!
Der Prüfer ist schon perfekt zufrieden.
Wenn Sie ein bisschen über die Lunge was sagen,
ich gucke mir an, ob er eingelagert hat,
wassereinlagerungen hat im Körper, vor allen Dingen an den Beinen.
Und dann gucke ich mir an,
ob die... fertig, reicht schon.
Weiter.
Und bei der Labo veranlasse ich
große Blutbild-
Herzenzümmen,
erst Enzymen,
ja, und
Cholesterinwärze,
Leber und Nierenwärze.
Und
vielleicht Dedyme.
Vielleicht?
Ja, Dedyme.
Um irgendwie zu ausschließen.
Ja, aber was ist das Allerwichtigste?
Sie haben gesagt, Ihre Hauptdiagnosis
Herzunsuffizienz.
Dann müssen Sie das erste erwähnen,
was Herzunsuffizienz einzeigt im Labor.
BNP.
Ah, BNP, natürlich.
Ja, nee.
Also wenn Sie sagen Herzunsuffizienz, müssen Sie auch
BNP sagen.
Ja, BNP und auch Pro-BNP.
Genau, wir machen erst das Pro-BNP
und dann natürlich auch die Dedymeere.
KVDW abhacken,
für jetzt.
Ich mache im Labor erst mal
Luftholzes Blutbild, Elektrolytik,
CAP, dann die Leberwerte,
also die Transmaminasen sagen wir natürlich.
Und dann machen wir
die
Gerinnungsparameter.
Was ganz wichtig ist, wir machen natürlich
das Pro-BNP, wir machen die Dedymeere,
wir machen als nächstes
ACS, Herzentime und Troponin.
Fertig.
Strategisch. Das ist besser.
Wenn man so vorgeht, ist es für sich auch besser
für die Prüfung. Glauben Sie es mir?
Ja, ja. Abhack. Okay, was machen Sie als
nächstes? Sehr gut.
Ja, und
anschließend veranstalten Sie
ein paar Apparativuntersuchungen.
Erste Wahl,
Sonografie
und EKG.
Was machen Sie als
erstes?
Sie können nicht zuerst Sonografie sagen.
Erste ist EKG.
Ja, aber das haben Sie ja schon gemacht.
Sie müssen sagen, wir haben
ja schon Pause gemacht, weil der Patient
Luftnot angegeben hat.
Die Vitalparameter habe ich schon überprüft.
Was sind Vitalparameter?
Atemnotrhythmus und
Atemnotrhythmus?
Was ist ein Atemnotrhythmus?
Atemrhythmus und
Herzrhythmus und das
Atemfrequenz.
Frequenz.
Atemfrequenz, nicht Atemrhythmus.
Atemfrequenz.
Herzrhythmus, Sauerstoff,
Sättigung, Blutdruck
und Puls.
Puls, Oximetrie. Sie haben ja schon EKG geschrieben.
Sehr gut. Super.
Also erst EKG, so weiter.
Dann?
Sonografie, das Herz ist
Ekko.
Herzultraschall.
Das heißt Herzultraschall.
Ich mache einen Herzultraschall.
Herzultraschall und
gegebenenfalls
eine
Diacetetestorax.
Sehr gut. Wovon machen Sie das abhängig?
Ja, aufgrund
der Disponente
und um die...
Wovon machen Sie abhängig? Ob Sie das
CT machen oder nicht? Wovon hängt das ab?
Wovon machen Sie das abhängig?
Das CT.
Sie haben gesagt, gegebenenfalls
noch ein CT.
Wenn die Befunde nicht unklar sind.
Das meine ich. Der Prüfer sagt das genauso.
Wovon machen Sie das abhängig?
Ja.
Und? Nehbarle.
Wovon machen Sie das abhängig?
Ja, hängt ab
unklare Befunde.
Ja, von welchem Befund hängt das ab?
Zum Beispiel
bei der
Herzultraschallbefunde
und auch...
Wann würden Sie es machen?
Wie muss das Herzultraschall sein, damit Sie
ein CT machen von der Lunge?
Zum Beispiel
wenn wir
keine Ursache
zum Beispiel...
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein
Jetzt können Sie sagen
Rechtsherz. Jetzt dürfen Sie Rechtsherz
sagen. Ja.
Bei Lunge ist rechtsherz bewahren. Wenn Sie
im Herzultraschall Rechtsherzbelastungszeichen
sehen, wenn das rechte Herz nicht
gut pumpt, wenn das rechte Herz getroffen
ist, ja. Und
und... und... Labor,
welcher Wert?
Nein, nein, CT. Warum machen Sie das CT überhaupt?
Ah, okay, wenn D-D-Mehr erhöht.
Ja, ja, okay, wirklich, das ist wichtig. Das heißt, wir machen das davon abhängig,
da kann das fragen, wenn Sie sagen, Sie machen gegebenenfalls noch ein CT. Warum machen Sie das CT?
Wovon machen Sie das abhängig? Sie machen das abhängig von der D-D-Mehre. Wenn die D-D-Mehre normal ist
und er keine Rechtssatzbelastungszeichen hat, dann brauchen Sie auch kein CT zu machen.
Ja, natürlich.
Wenn eines von beiden, wenn D-D-Mehre komplett unauffällig ist und er hat Rechtssatzbelastungszeichen,
dann müssen Sie das auch nicht machen, weil die D-D-Mehre ist schon sehr ausschlaggebend.
Wenn die ganz normal ist, unauffällig ist, dann müssen Sie das auch nicht machen.
Man kann auch schlicht.
Dann muss das Recht herzintuizient sein, einfach im Rahmen der Herzinsuizienz.
Ja, aber wenn die D-D-Mehre erhöht ist, müssen Sie auf jeden Fall ein CT machen.
Okay?
Okay.
Gut, was noch? Das reicht.
Das reicht.
Was Sie machen könnten ist, wenn der Patient eine Lungenembolie hat im CT.
Welche Untersuchungen müssen Sie dann noch machen?
Fluoroskopie.
Bitte, was?
Was ist eine Fluoroskopie?
Oder Lungenstimme.
Nein, nein, nein! Nein!
Der Patient hat schon eine Lungenembolie im CT.
Wenn der Patient eine gesicherte CT im CT eine Lungenembolie hat.
Eine Geografie.
Nein.
Guck mal, der Patient hat eine Lungenembolie.
Jetzt steht fest, dass es seine Krankung ist.
Er hat eine Lungenembolie, deswegen hat er Luftnot.
Welche Untersuchungen muss man dann noch machen?
Denken Sie an die Beine.
Okay.
Beinwehnendoppler. Das rechte Bein ist dicker.
Ah, natürlich.
Wir müssen die Pongos ausschließen.
Ja, ich weiß, das ist die Aufregung, aber in der Prüfung müssen Sie das wissen.
Ja, natürlich müssen wir das wissen.
Genau. Also, CT, wenn der Patient eine gesicherte Lungenembolie hat, muss man noch nach den Beinen gucken.
Woher das kommt.
Ja, super.
Gut.
Ja, und sollte sich meine Verdachtstheoretik zu bestätigen,
lerne ich therapeutische Maßnahmen.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ja, und Leben steht Änderungen.
Der Patient ist jetzt bei Ihnen und hat jetzt akute Luftnot und Sie wissen, es ist eine Herzunzufizienz.
Was machen Sie als Allererstes?
Ja, natürlich Sauerstoffgabe.
Und was noch?
Sie müssen verhandeln.
Das Wasser muss raus aus der Lunge. Denken Sie mal logisch nach. Was gehen Sie dann?
Und dann A.S.S.?
Nein.
Wenn er eine Herzunzufizienz hat und er hat Wasser in der Lunge, der hat Luftnot.
Was ist die erste Therapie der Wahl?
Die Therapie ist die Diuretika.
Ah, genau. Ich verabreiche ihm die Diuretika am besten über die Vene.
Entschuldigung.
Ja, alles gut.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ich komme in eine Minute.
Ja.
Die Diuretika und dann genau. Und was müssen Sie dann noch behandeln? Die Herzunzufizienz.
Das ist wichtig. Ich muss die Herzunzufizienz behandeln, müssen Sie sagen.
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, zuerst Sauerstoffgabe, die Diuretika und diese langfristige Therapie muss ich planen.
Sehr gut. Die langfristige Therapie für eine Herzunzufizienz.
Eine Herzunzufizienz-Therapie müssen Sie einleiten, sagen Sie so.
Ich muss eine Herzunzufizienz-Therapie einleiten. Die besteht aus was?
Ja, aus...
Ja, Beta-Blocco.
Ja.
Clopidogrel. Oder?
Clopidogrel ist Blutverdünnung.
Ja, natürlich. Vielleicht. Ja.
Nein, Sie reden von der Herzunzufizienz.
Ja, Beta-Blocco, Diuretika und...
Was ist das Mittel? Was sind die Therapie für Herzunzufizienz?
Also Herzunzufizienz-Therapie, Beta-Blocco, leitliniengerecht, ACE-Hemmer.
Ja, ACE-Hemmer, ARB auch, Angiotensin-Receptor-Blocco.
Was gehört noch? Es gibt vier, die eine Säule bilden, die man geben muss,
wenn der wirklich eine Herzunzufizienz hat.
Das heißt, wenn die EF eingeschränkt ist, unter 45 zum Beispiel, hat er ja wahrscheinlich.
ACE-Hemmer, Beta-Blocco, was noch?
ARB, Angiotensin-Receptor-Blocco.
Sehr gut. Und was ist das Vierte?
Wenn Sie das nicht sagen, das müssen Sie sagen.
In allen Leitlinien hochgepriesen, SGLT2-Hemmer.
SGLT2-Hemmer, das muss jeder von euch wissen.
S, Gross S, Gross E.
S, Gross GLT2.
Hemmer. Lüttfern, wunne herkes googeln japür bugön.
SGLT2-Hemmer ist Mittel der Wahl, Dapagliflozin oder Empagliflozin ist das.
Jardins zum Beispiel ist Empagliflozin, Foxiga ist Dapagliflozin.
Das brauchen die Medikamente, das brauchen die Patienten.
Das ist leitlinengerecht Klasse 1a.
Und was man auch wissen muss, ist, diese SGLT2-Hemmer gibt man auch bei Patienten mit einer HEPF-PEF.
Das heißt, wenn die Pumpfunktion noch gut ist, aber er trotzdem eine Herzunsuffizienz hat, gibt es ja auch.
Egal, muss man nicht wissen.
Also SGLT2-Hemmer, ACE-Hemmer, Beta-Blocco, ARB.
Super. Gut?
Ich weiß, dass man sich mit der Freude ein paar Dinge verabschieden kann.
Insgezamtmusik, zahnamnesa, almanja, Superdene.
Also es war wirklich gut.
Ich kann sagen, dass es in der Verkaufsweise und im Anliegen alles gut war.
Die Diagnostik war auch am Anfang sehr gut.
Dann haben wir es etwas verabschieden.
Aber das ist nicht alles, aber das ist die Herzunsuffizienz.
Also Herzunsuffizienz, Medikament-Level, wirklich.
Tagtank auch, wenn sie es werden, können sie es lassen.
ACE-Hemmer, Beta-Blocco, Spinalakton.
Also altes Ohrenantagonist.
Und SGLT2-Hemmer.
Nur für Lienzki kriegt man ganz viele Punkte in der Prüfung.
Ja, okay. Mach ich.
Wenn kommt, mach ich.
Aber ja, genau. Okay?
Viel mehr.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die anderen noch Fragen haben.
Ja, ich würde es gerne machen.
Danke.
Es war ein guter Auftritt.
Waren Sie da? Ist das Ihr erster Mal?
Ja, das ist mein erster Mal.